cory craig
has historically presented problems for
mitchell this time
donovan mitchell knocks down the
mid-range jump shots go bear to
clear it out mitchell oh he punches it
home
three years jokic if you're seven feet
and you reach donovan mitchell just says
uh uh that's a big mistake and
how about the adjustment as grant comes
over fakes necessary to get to where he
wants
three of six from downtown
and jamal murray counters with his own
three his second field goal of the game
he's got five three-point ball game
murray
into traffic tough step back
[Music]
here's jokic in the middle of the floor
murray
got all the way to the paint and banks
at home with the left
lying jamal murray this is the shot
mechanics i'm talking about like
he should be a 50 40 90 guy got two
elite defenders on the the los angeles
clippers and an electric
player in luka doncic what happens there
speaking of electric
he's got the wattage blowing right now
donovan mitchell with the floater and
again another rudy gobert screen
and this is the toughest shot i mean
he's driving
utah by one marine jokic a little
two-man game murray gets it to ball
behind the gobear screen
driving mitchell finishing 45.
wow was that a back court that's what
quinn snyder was saying
murray for three got it hatched here
again
exclusively two-man game rejects the
screen
puts the three around the oak screen
hit him with the hesitation move murray
oh he's on fire
mitchell downhill stopped on a dime no
change for murray
just incredible shot making by two
separation with the step back how about
that
ridiculous stop and pull into your jump
shot motion
[Applause]
murray got all the way inside great
left-handed move
12 pounds stronger than he was a season
ago in the playoffs
looking for atonement this year juke's
ingles and he has it working 33 in the
game
for jamal murray
mitchell with a little get back got it
for a minute to go
off the yoke it's screen got free
raising up